have you ever this is a wild question
should they have an obvious no to it but
have you ever crowd surfed
nope one of these days I'm gonna get my
big ass up there they don't care you bro
they better but what you don't do is I
gotta wait till I'm like Beyonce or
Drake levels where I got life though my
mama I gotta like I'm like I'm gonna get
on my knees and just lay so what you do
is pause
I crossed a lot in my life you get into
the crowd and you find the biggest
[__]
right and then you just tap their
shoulder and you say and then they'll
get you up and then you start tapping
the people in front so then they'll tap
and then this is at Rock shows for the
most part or like a Tech N9ne concert
and then and then they'll then usually
everyone's in communication now what's
dangerous is when you just like out of
nowhere like yeah then you jump and your
fans aren't expecting you to do that one
you might die and two you might kill
someone
certain stages where I can't get down
bro go
lit
I just don't have money still trying to
[__] rob you you got a wheel you
gotta wait till we you gotta wait till
we like like super [__] stuff nah for
sure no for sure I feel like raw wave
could crowd surf right now
someone would die though
not if everybody's on the same page
everyone has to be on the same page you
gotta say hey hey
but yeah
that's why I said it's more of a you
gotta like sit down and just lay back
and just live yes you gotta do this
that's actually my favorite artist
that wasn't his fault that was all those
people that were on stage with him also
shout out to Rod wave one of my favorite
artists he's from St Petersburg Florida
which I used to live He's a sweet guy
too man yeah I like you know what I like
about Rod wave he's so anti-industry
yeah like he don't give a [__] about
being your friend he ain't trying to
kick it with rappers he's doing none of
the weirdo [__] he's just making records
I'm trying to kick you with your ride
listen listen bro I [__] with you I
don't even got to do no songs but I just
[__] with you and yeah I love Rod he and
he's like he can make country he can
make pop music I mean he's just such an
amazing songwriter that'll happen for
you man I mean it's gonna happen uh we
was just at uh G5 in Miami great place
he was there great chicken wings and the
wild it was they said he was there I
didn't see him that happened to him the
DJ said old Broadway or something
something what if the DJ accidentally
thought you were Rod wave that would be
[__] up because I get that all the
time I get this [__] out walked in and
the guys are like yo shout out to Rod
wave in the building and you you're like
what if that's what the [__] he was
talking about and then you're like do
you know a song you're like yo that's
dope broad waves here but DJ thought you
were wrong with me bro and he plays
fight the feeling and he's wondering why
you're not serious
he's like bro I'm playing fight the
feeling so what's [__] members I am
excited though cause I'm singing I'm a
singing word for word so that [__]
around
like before they are you are you out
no Okay you're from Texas
and it's like that every time are your
girls permanent are you possible
permanent so I had one of my first nah
take it out my first Grill was it was a
pull out but a dog like the smile a
Yorkie like literally chewed the tip I
had diamonds missing and some more [__]
and I was like never again I had a when
I went through my girlfriends it was
because I live in Florida everybody in
Florida got grills grills so the Jeweler
just just gave me some grills and uh man
I just I couldn't get used to him bro
and then and then you know what I
realized because I would talk to dudes
with grills right
and I'd be like yo why everybody I know
into in Florida
and also could say a lot about the type
of guys I was in for close proximity
with talking to just have like really
bad breath
and I was like
my breath funky because I got metal in
my mouth I don't know
I just stop wearing them so
it's really like you're supposed to go
get your [__] clean you are you supposed
to go get them took out and clean every
I think it's like every three
no no it's not it's not it's like every
three months you're supposed to go back
to the dentist he take them off take
your actual teeth off
so like they it's like they're cementing
on my on your actual yeah they shaved
your teeth down underneath yeah yeah but
they didn't just they didn't Kodak my
[__] no I know I understand but what
you're saying is every three months
they're supposed to take the Caps off
yeah but clean them off they scrape they
get the semen off clean my teeth yeah
and then I take the actual diamonds and
shoot to Johnny they clean them that's a
Johnny Dang girl wow I'll go back to to
the dentist you put them back on that's
why that's crazy [__] commitment yeah
how long before you say [__] this [__]
and you get veneers I'm ready for
veneers I was gonna say six months
yo I feel like everybody who has the
grills at least besides Birdman who I
think recently took him out because
Birdman was committed shout out to him
but all the homies I know who are
younger they get the grills the perms
and I see them like two months later two
years later or something and they just
they got them pearly whites
it's always because right it's only
because I just never thought that I
would lose a like a diamond would come
out of
I don't know I just I didn't even notice
it was missing I was in [__] Arizona
recording
so I didn't even know I I just I never
knew to somebody pointed with that that
damn Diamond's missing and then you
gotta you got special toothpaste
uh you can I mean you can just it's
certain two places that you can use like
I use any toothpaste right but it's like
this black one that you can use that
it's supposed to be the charcoal yeah
but I don't think you're making a
difference and you you just pop yours
out at night back to it I've been seeing
him do that [__] sometimes and I just go
I know you feel so relieved yeah but
it's like I don't know I don't feel like
it'll make a difference
well your only option after this is
veneers you can't go back now you need
veneers yeah which would I mean don't
get them super crazy
[__] out here looking crazy
these [__] artists out here got
these [__] teeth
these fools got these [__] surfboards
bro what's up and it's like oh I see
what you did there
the most unnatural looking [__] horse
smile in the world yeah Mama go with the
person who put my perms in Bollywood
he'd do me the Javonte Davis teeth you
do all the
different one he did finesse two times
teeth he did 2 Chainz Got Some Teeth
yeah who doesn't have teeth right now
everybody's got veneers you know what
sucks is we have like a whole entire
generation of hip-hop artists
who have little weird fangs underneath
their fake teeth
yeah
yeah see my my boots are nasty did you
see uh shout out to Texas B King he
actually posted the picture yeah with no
teeth oh my God I appreciated him
showing everybody like this is what this
[__] yeah yeah and that was just with
veneers he never had a group right he
had veneers yeah yeah I guess he just
got all his [__] actually pulled out and
got like implants yeah the main plants
is the wave but they're real painful as
[__] takes a while bro
because you've seen he just he just lost
a tooth had to go get a redone he was
eating something in the tooth by the way
Texas Legend yeah for sure for sure him
little runny mother F yeah oh yeah I'd
like to attribute all of the Cucumber
action of like 2018 and 2017. all those
two definitely went there oh my God I
remember seeing like trouble in boozy
did you remember seeing that IG live
pool party yes I was like what the [__]
and then you ever been to a party like
that no I would I wouldn't want to go
I'm married oh yeah
my wife would not approve yeah now
somebody who looked like me and had
similar interests as me that was not
married
I cannot confirm nor just confirm that
they would enjoy such events don't get
in trouble
but me would not enjoy it I wouldn't
even first of all if I win I'd hate it
great man I had a terrible time right
yeah smoothie
it's kind of crazy uh all right man
we'll look the tour is going crazy so
congratulations on the tour appreciate
you it's uh how am I you guys are almost
done yeah we went over past halfway
through it but then right after this
tour we're on Kevin Gates tour so Wow
have you met Kevin yet another person
though you guys are gonna have a fun
time he's a very good guy he's also
intense
but he's like a hugger you know what I'm
saying like if he [__] with you you're
gonna you guys are gonna hug if you
don't [__] with you I don't know yeah
hey you wouldn't be on but he's a great
dude hit me you might end up Muslim at
the end of the tour though
yeah man I feel with Kevin Gates man I
feel like all the rappers are kicking
with Kevin Gates they're Muslim right
after like shout out to [__] NBA
young boys Muslim money back yo got a
nice little movement going on what's
Happening you hung out with Kevin Gates
yeah hey shout out to my Muslim brothers
and sisters out there you you hey man
you gonna be praying you're gonna be
praying with Kevin Gates on that tour
Chelsea yeah I gotta do a record
together yeah for sure that'd be crazy
yeah but no we need to work on Rod wave
and big X the plug doing a song together
man we don't even got to do that I just
we just need to be friends right you
need me as a friend have a good time
yeah yeah he's almost like two bowling
balls just rolling just having the time
of their life I'm glad you said that
because I had to if I knew it was coming
I knew it was coming
all right so uh you and Diego are
putting out a project together and then
you and him
ours probably gonna come first okay or
it's not even just me and he is it's
like a like I said this is something
entertainment so I'm looking I'm looking
to sign maybe like two more artists go
before we put the project in nice
so do we gonna do that then I'm gonna do
the Avo then me and then pull in Dallas
are you trying to put Dallas on or is it
just if somebody could be from where
just I just I just want talent I want
people that's actually hard and it's
actually doing it for the right reasons
you know what I'm saying like I'm I'm
big on loyalty and like just standing on
something in general so that's what I
look for I don't you can be the hardest
rapper in the world but if you're a if
you're a hoe
ain't that the truth
I'm just glad you came through man I
appreciate you for having me pickaxe the
plug of course we're gonna have him
freestyle so you're gonna be able to see
that if you were missing any packages
you know they don't know what happened a
woman has allegedly got it allegedly man
[__] FedEx